I want to go back to something that you
said regarding figuring out what the
initial fan that concentric circle then
the very very core when he family and
friends mhm what if that's not a high
number do you still watch a crowdfunding
campaign so the question is what do you
do if your immediate community isn't
that large and the answer is you don't
try to squeeze blood from a stone so you
can use crowdfunding as a tool to build
your community if you do it slowly and
responsibly and you're prepared to
deliver on your promises at each phase
so the cool thing that's been happening
in crowdfunding is the use of staged
financing and so on seed and spark for
example you only open one page for your
film and you can do successive
crowdfunding campaigns inside that state
same page and build your funders and
followers and accrue an audience in a
single place right one of the best ways
we ever saw this used was a filmmaker
named Liam Brady who had been at NYU
Tisch just head down making movies
becoming an auteur right and it was time
for him to make his thesis film and he
looked up and the landscape had changed
and he was like wow I really want to
crowdfund this film and I have a couple
of problems the first is my community
isn't that big right now because I
haven't been cultivating it and I'm a
little bit sensitive about going to my
friends and family who have kind of
helped me fund other movies that I made
earlier - I actually don't have the
script all the way developed because
it's dependent a little bit on casting
but I don't have money to hire a casting
director and how do I really kind of
kick it up the next notch and I need to
do readings with actors but that means I
have to get space and I have to you know
and I really need some materials to
build audiences and get the word out and
kind of glad-hand a little bit so he
decided to run a 6,000 dollar
development campaign for a film called
fog city and he was going to hire a
casting director
he was going to print some marketing
materials he was going to do
some like table reads and make sure that
he could pay for a space and feed his
actors imagine that and and then throw a
party also to give people a sense of the
other work that he's done to really like
offer something to the community to say
here's what I'm here to do I would
really love for you to join me and he
said about this development campaign he
ran a 60-day campaign which is a long
time to crowd fund and he raised six
thousand six hundred dollars he actually
he was funded within 30 days because it
was a it was a very good crowdfunding
video it was a very successful he was
very dialed in and his outreach and he
does all this work and he does you know
the sixty six hundred dollar campaign he
develops the script just as he promised
he keeps the audience updated along the
way and as a result of all of these
things he was doing and executing on the
promises he made in the first campaign
people approached him from his community
and said I would like to get involved in
this film in a more material way this
film really matters to me and so he did
the development he needed he got it cast
as he needed he knew at that point how
much the production would cost him like
when he ran the development campaign he
didn't even know how much to ask for
for the full film because it wasn't
developed well enough it was gonna it
was cast dependent and things like that
so he got a fully developed script he
knew how much the cast would cost him he
could price it out and because these
people had approached him and said I
want to get involved in a more
meaningful way he felt confident going
out and asking for the full production
budget of the film not the
post-production just the production
budget of the film thirty-five thousand
thirty three thousand dollars he does a
33 thousand dollar campaign less than
five months before the first campaign
but on the back of this wider community
of support that he had built executing
exactly proving himself trustworthy
along the way building a tremendous
amount of social capital creating of
evangelists of all the people who had
you know contributed to this first
smaller campaign he raised thirty five
thousand dollars in 30 days in this
second campaign also because he learned
a lot about the way his community wanted
be spoken to his second pitch video is
quite a bit different it reached out in
a different way but he said very clearly
this is not for post-production I'm
going to crowdfund again for post so he
goes and he shoots the film and he
starts editing the film and nine months
later when he knows exactly what he
needs to get through the like full
festival submission post-production
music period he does another 30-day
campaign for $6,000 this time making an
extraordinarily tongue-in-cheek
crowdfunding video because he built up
the film is a drama about a veteran and
a baseball team and it's it's sort of
dark and deep and beautiful but the
pitch video was utterly irreverent
because at this point he had built up
such a rapport with his audience that he
knew how he could speak to them without
sort of futzing with the tone of the
film or the gravitas of the campaign
raised $6,000 by himself in his sleep
only because he had done all of this
work in advance and that got him to
fifty seven thousand dollars for a short
film that was his nyu thesis film which
is now out you know submitted to
festivals so question when he did his
initial outreach for the six thousand
plus in the very beginning and he'd had
his head down he'd been busy with
classes what was the outreach because
what did he go on social media oh yeah I
know he spent he spent two months three
months on social media in advance making
sure that everybody he knew knew that
this was coming down the pipeline nobody
was surprised they're like Liam
launching a crowdfunding campaign no
everybody knew this was coming right the
second piece of it is a tremendous
amount of email outreach reconnecting
with people he had been connecting
connecting with he moved back to San
Francisco from New York during this time
and like reconnected with like the Film
Society community and like went to
events and met filmmakers in his
community learned who he would need to
outreach to there there was a lot of
like in-person outreach that he was
doing in the months in the event in
advance of his campaign I see okay so it
wasn't just you know what this is the
dollar amount I need for the beginning
and I'm
launched the Twitter now and I'm gonna
do the Instagram he started it well in
advance oh yeah you know you can't start
your relationship with your audience by
asking them for money
that's absurd on its face you have to
start by getting them really excited
about what you're gonna offer them if
only you have the resources and that's a
process you know this isn't a light
switch you can flip on it just isn't and
I don't feel sorry to say that to people
it's like the the people you see like
louis c.k and Ed Burns who are
gloriously benefiting from the direct
relationship they have with their
audience that's something that they took
the time energy and intention to
cultivate right long before they you
know were stars of stage and screen
actually Ed Burns told me that it was
Ted Hope who sat him down and was like
dude if your careers in a slump you need
a Twitter account so you know it also
isn't necessarily true that you know
your fame will carry you or yeah we just
have to get out of this universe of
somebody's gonna hand it to me or
somebody's gonna pick me no you have to
go and pick them you have to go and pick
your audience one by one and tell them
why they should join your journey that's
the work that's the work
you